quem nunca postou uma foto nas redes
sociais só para curtir o pior ainda
ficou de cinco em cinco minutos olhando
a foto e depois perceber quantas
partidas tinham bons a metade do exame
pitt é verdade que a gente vive na era
digital
no momento da imagem eu lembro que
quando era menor
ainda no ensino fundamental tinha uma
amiguinha que uma amiguinha que era mais
popular da minha sala e ótima boneca e
daquele momento ela me negou a prestar
boneca dela porque ela diz que era muito
forte tinha e que eu corri o risco de eu
estragar algo na casa dela
gente eu era uma criança gorda e nerd
eu não preciso nem dizer eu fui uma das
últimas do meu grupo a perder o bebê
meu nome é que a festa é que ela estava
no cantinho dançando enquanto as minhas
amigas dá um beijão os outros meninos e
com o tempo naquele momento apesar disso
tudo tá com pessoas horas eu sempre uma
pessoa muito social que gostava está com
muita gente ao redor
naquele momento a gente já tinha o
recreio da vontade de bairro
a gente já pôde na casa um do outro - a
passar a tarde junto mas com o tempo as
coisas foram se perdendo porque cada
roupa para alugar um espaço na vida e as
redes sociais passaram a ser o único
lugar que a gente tinha pra conhecer
saber um pouco mais como tava vida um do
outro
você sabe como funciona a rede social né
eu tenho uma roupinha nova lá tudo
bonitinho que vai ser posta a viagem
maravilhosa tem uma foto massa você
posta conseguir uma proposta nova de
emprego você pode a gente gosta tudo mas
o problema é que a gente aposta o
sucesso e com o tempo comecei a postar
minhas coisas também
ano passado foi um ano muito
transformador muito louco pra mim porque
eu encontrei dois amigos do ensino médio
que não via há muitos anos
e ainda vencendo mas não tínhamos feito
um projeto de iniciação científica tinha
pesquisado junto tema educação
financeira voltada para o público jovem
e nós percebemos o quanto isso mudou a
nossa vida é como jovem adulto sem grana
e essa é a oportunidade ia fazer uma
palestra sobre isso para alguns jovens
de ensino médio
foi o que a gente percebeu que tinha uma
oportunidade de negócio e fazer o que a
gente gostava que era passar
conhecimento das pessoas e ao mesmo
tempo ganhar com isso
e foi aí que eu me transformei numa
jovem empreendedora conheço gera novas
oportunidades né palestras prêmios eu
tava sempre postando na rede
falando das coisas conhecendo muita
gente nova e essas pessoas viraram
contato da minha vida da minha rede e as
pessoas ao meu redor meus amigos família
até ser esquecidos que sabiam que eu era
começar a entender como uma menina de
sucesso até tem uma uma pesquisa é feito
por outros cientistas da universidade da
califórnia nos estados unidos que disse
guerra curtida das suas redes sociais
ativa libera uma quantidade maior de
dopamina numa área específica do cérebro
responsável pelo prazer e que isso é
mesma coisa que você comeu um pedaço de
chocolate tem um orgasmo ou ganhar
dinheiro
imagina quando eu estava feliz né com
todas aquelas curtindo as minhas redes
sociais
só que não é que ninguém sabia é que na
minha vida pessoal
eu tinha acabado de descobrir que a
minha mãe tinha alguns dos miomas no
útero que ela ia precisar operar e teve
trombose na época foi o primeiro momento
que houve durante os 20 anos que eu vi
minha mãe numa cama de hospital
nesse meio tempo a minha cachorrinha que
já estava com a gente há alguns anos
faleceu e foi presente da minha mãe
durante a separação dos meus pais quando
tinha 10 anos ela foi minha melhor amiga
naquele momento minha avó com alzheimer
avançado é tava cada vez mais debilitada
e eu me virar sozinha depressiva ansiosa
no relacionamento na época
dois pontos meu namorado me largou a 2
eu ia sozinho ali mas as minhas redes
sociais
aí não tinham fotos minhas viajando em
poderá das minhas palestras com um
pezinho na areia da praia
aquela foto de terça feira à tarde cabe
à cvm foi a nossa inveja então é só
postar duas fotinhos mas ninguém sabia
que por trás daquela daquele pezinho na
areia tinha uma cara inchada estão
chorar sem saber o que fazer da minha
vida
bom nesse momento eu comecei a entrar
nas redes sociais é buscar os amigos que
eu tinha eu não encontrava porque eles
não sabiam que estava acontecendo na
minha vida de verdade que eles sabiam
que eles viam eram forte e eu também não
sabia que tava acontecendo na vida de
verdade deles né porque eu também vieram
postagem ti no nas redes
eu vi uma conhecida uma menina que eu
falava muito pouco ela postou que ela
estava passando por um processo de
transtorno de ansiedade
ela fez um texto falando sobre isso eu
me identifiquei com cada uma das linhas
uma palavra sobre todas a irritabilidade
a sensação de fracasso as mãos geladas
tremendo insônia dor de cabeça era tudo
que eu tinha naquele momento que eu
estava passando e eu tomei coragem de
chamar ano no bate papo e perguntar como
ela tava falar que eu tinha lido o texto
e ela perguntou como eu estava
foi o primeiro momento que eu disse olha
eu tô bem mal
e aqui o som limpas sem parecer que eu
tinha falado porque é o primeiro momento
que eu consegui dizer a verdade sobre o
que estava sentindo na minha vida
respondeu toda fofa me chamou para sair
falou vamos tomar cerveja vamos
conversar mais sobre isso ele o que a
gente encontrou nós ficamos três horas
falando sobre a vida andando várias
dicas de como poderia lidar melhor com a
ansiedade e eu dei algumas diretamente
como ela poderia viajar com menos né
passar o sonho dela e nós nos tornamos
amigas e eu percebi naquele momento como
era importante a gente está vulnerável
idade bom
o internacional passou né
o site virou as coisas melhoraram minha
faculdade abrir um processo
é é seletivo pra fazer um intercâmbio eu
apliquei passei eu fui pro portugal
fiquei seis meses lá voltei com um
pouquinho tempo e foi um momento muito
mágico assim eu voltei muito animada mas
dez quilos mais gorda e imaginei que as
pessoas que me viram assim algumas
pessoas faltaram alguns comentários em
mim né
nossa você engordou eu comecei a ficar
chateada que eu falei que sabia fazer a
postagem da minha rede social falou aqui
ó
embora aí sim eu sei que engordei eu sei
que toda a escola não é gorda eu sei que
eu tô comendo mal que estou dormindo
pouco eu vou trabalhando demais
sei que fim não tendo tempo de fazer
exercícios e disso tudo mas eu também
sei que nesse momento da minha vida
estou muito mais preocupada com a pessoa
que eu estou me tornando do que com
essas gordurinhas bay coisa mas o que a
gente pode que apareceram e eu mesmo fui
expulso e essa exposição fez com que
outras pessoas principalmente mulheres
pensem falar comigo no bate papo dizendo
que ela estava passando por algo muito
parecido na vida delas que elas também
ouviam comentários do namorado fábio
tinha guardado ou piadinhas no ambiente
de trabalho e conversando né gente
trocando experiência mas percebemos que
caber em uma calça 36 não é não é o
sinônimo de sucesso
foi aí que eu tive certeza que buner
habilidade uma coisa muito importante
falar nas coisas que estão acontecendo
na sua vida sabe se abrir para o outro
sucesso pra mim hoje em dia pode falar
com pessoas vão poder ouvir e ser ouvida
é eu tenho o contato com o cliente todos
os dias por causa da empresa eu sei que
eles falam de experiências eles contam
histórias e cada uma dessas histórias
são como se fossem pedacinhos assim que
eu vou lindo e vou encontrando nela e
melhorando sabe vendo com rua existem
realidade diferente da minha e como isso
é maravilhoso assim poder fazer parte
disso e eu comecei a colocar isso em
prática na nas redes sociais ou enfim no
google quando a gente vai pesquisar na
internet o significado de vôo
a habilidade o que aparece como
resultado é sinônimo dia fraqueza
insegurança incapacidade de fazer algo e
pra mim mostrar sua fraqueza é sinônimo
de corais em só os corajosos consegue
falar dos seus defeitos falar das ações
das suas fraquezas dos seus erros sem
tornar isso algo negativo e continua de
boa em relação a isso então eu gostaria
de convidar vocês e dizer por favor
parem de suas bandeiras das duas
personalidades de seus defeitos de seus
erros não é um problema
na verdade se desenvolve a auto
conhecimento se desenvolve a auto
libertação
nós estamos aqui numa sala cheia de
gente olha para essas pessoas cada uma
delas e perceba que elas são mais do que
rostos do que cabelo do que uma roupa ou
de um perfil numa rede social
elas têm coração ela tem pensamento elas
falam pensam se pode criar conexões
incríveis com as pessoas que estão ao
seu redor se você olhar para elas e
ligue para as pessoas discutirem sabe
aquele poder de quem de verdade são
paulo liga para sua avó que você não vê
tanto tempo ou enfim vão parar de ficar
naquela dia vou marcar marcar e marcar
com um grupo de amigos com amigos e
nunca conseguir ligar sua fala
ressaltando a sua casa agora falar com
você porque é muito importante é muito
gostoso sentir importante e fazer com
que as pessoas ao seu redor se sinta
importante também e isso pra mim é
sucesso hoje em dia de eleições elas
valem mais de partida e sim obrigado
[Aplausos]